citizens of the reject Nation Greg here
John how are you I am excited and and
intrepidatious and all sorts of things
but more importantly how are you doing
cheese shut up I'm in a terrible mood
I can't tell it's okay don't worry we're
gonna watch the finale run of Gravity
Falls today this is uh x x PC whatever
all right let's see what's going on so
guys leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated and subscribe and click that
Bell to get notified when our next
reaction for Gravity Falls is up only a
few episodes left and of course full
interaction watch along is where you
sync up with your own copy for Gravity
Falls available for super sexy rejects
on our patreon page prepper you guys are
good you good good team let's get to it
[Music]
oh it's happening it's finally finally
happening
whoa
what just happened
oh oh man this is bad
this is terribly
bill you can call me
your nightmares I call my friends oh wow
[Music]
Veronica pacifier and these guys this is
our town now boys
you Unholy triangle fella as mayor I
strongly urge you to get
get on out of here yeah things with what
I are weird
perhaps I can be one of your uh Horsemen
of the Apocalypse not now sweetie the
grown-ups are talking how about instead
I shuffle the functions of every hole in
your face
oh wow hi that is horrific
time we do
we do it creating I
it's a Daft Punk concert
ing has no meaning
weird oh
sure defeating bill is even possible I'm
not sure but being a hero means fighting
back even when it seems in impossible
will you follow me to the ends of the
Earth
I would never be a hero
[Applause]
Surf and weirdness wave
Abuelita a tidal wave of Madness just
went over us
when the universe is broken only one
handyman can fix it I'm Coming For You
friends time for a nap
hey that's it Goat it's time I threw you
off this property for good
Jesus
second thought I'm gonna run like a
coward now
[Music]
audio is weird
hey
DMX prison life worth living
would a goat eat a building
Cthulhu what are you doing here
All For You
oh no hide
you well well well and here I thought
today couldn't get any better
oh my God your Hat's still alive I know
know your weakness Bill oh yeah and I
know a riddle why did the old man do
this
oh Han soloed
scratcher
this is hell
no
that's right don't be a hero kid this is
what happens to heroes in my world
no no that's like all the answers
hence Maniacs roll out
oh oh yeah oh yeah
Dracula
do not summon at all we are day three in
this strange cataclysmic event which
some are calling we are gonna get it or
the odd apocalypse
oh no hey hey you hey I want to talk to
you I want to talk to you about going
inside my mouth I I think you want
hey I'm
take a big deal out of it
seriously rude to just ignore someone
like this
Stan Mabel uh maybe at least I can get
something to eat
perfect play to nachos
guess it's sort of cool they're paranoia
paid off so
let me get that for you
Wendy I'm so glad the nachos
dude
we were playing truth or dare in the
cemetery when it happened the eyeballs
froze Nate Lee tambry and Thompson I
remember them all perfectly well
Thompson Toby you watch the camp don't
call me Toby anymore wowie call me
Bodacious t no one will ever call you
that oh I got you Bodacious tea this is
so inventive I love it it's so creative
journals are destroyed Ford is captured
and I can't find my family anywhere Bill
said it himself there's no room for
Heroes out here we lost
no you have it how are we going to get
out there without being caught I have an
idea
does this group their names are like an
acronym for the title of this episode
when we're done partying I
have enough weird where did we get it ah
let me do the talking
[Music]
the baby
how's that how about this
oh snap he just killed time baby
God no
no
are you worried he might try to cause
some trouble yeah trouble with Mabel's
bubble
huh
I've got someone on the case
[Music]
I feel like it's Gideon must be Gideon
I've always wanted to drive a tank I
can't believe this place is just
abandoned oh
oh right to the cranium start to keep me
Tony was it Tony I can never remember
his name
round Walkers ain't got no wheels
listen Discount Auto Warriors huh y'all
Fellers wait Gideon
under the authority of Bill Cipher I
place you two under arrest this son of a
bee old pal Bill figured you might try
to rescue Mabel so he appointed me
master of these wastelands and Keeper of
the bubble the precious Maples trapped
inside and I have the only key you're a
perver man
around this little pocket of fat under
my head Gideon you have no right here in
there I'm gonna wear your butt on my
foot like a rhinestone slipper
yeah and what makes you think you can do
all that cause I'm a flipping corduroy
whoa
damn get back or I will drop kick him I
swear you'll never get away with this
you hear me guess what we already did oh
sweet or not
Warriors roll
[Applause]
ER he was outraged Gideon tenchman
unlock the bubble save Mabel save the
world
quick question did you ever get your
driver's license definitely not
she's doing a great job
oh
[Applause]
so disturbing remind me why you're
keeping your girlfriend in a prison
bubble again have we the prisoners
become the wardens she just doesn't know
yet now quit the philosophy sorry it was
my major your deep ghost eyes
[Applause]
it's like a crazy Mario Kart level
wowza
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is so inventive total lack of
drivers training don't fail me now
Thelma and Louise
[Music]
if that no almost there
[Music]
how's it deuce
Bill hatchbacks will be here any minute
to retrieve y'all Mabel's mine now
is she well yeah I have her trapped uh
look inside Gideon if all this is for
Mabel then ask yourself what Mabel would
want you to do
you got a possess her man
of course I hope you're right about this
bill's minions are gonna be on us in
seconds but I'm not gonna let that dumb
triangle be the war to me y'all ready
for a good old-fashioned prison bro what
yes this really happening
fighting a chaos God sounds fun let's do
this
[Music]
they're due for here
okay remember guys this is a prison
bubble designed by Bill gotta prepare
ourselves for what we find in whatever
orders we'll do it together for Mabel
for Mabel
Marvel leaks
[Music]
oh holy [ __ ] ah false alarms just a bird
not one person not one person is gone in
my mouth I don't care anymore I just I
gotta call my mother
uh that's Alex Hirsch right I think so
yeah yeah it's the same voice yeah
wow what a wild episode yeah that was
awesome that was incredible that was
dark neon demonic I loved it it was
everything I could ever want in my
animated kids show that's like an
imagination bomb I keep hoping he ends
up with Wendy he's earned it man he
started it yes he has I love that line
about uh you can't force someone to love
you but the most you can do is become
someone worthy of being loved or
something along those lines I don't know
I don't necessarily agree with that
sentiment but I think it's a nice thing
to think it sounds pretty it sounds
pretty and it sounds moralistically
right but sounds like what I should be
agreeing with if you can have someone
uh what's that called when you keep
someone hostage long enough and then a
Stockholm yeah if you can do Stockholm
syndrome that's a much more efficient
way to cut through all the bowl
but you know in terms of a kid show it's
probably a decent message to instill I
mean if you could avoid stocking
yeah you know I mean if you don't want
to be a hard worker if you don't want to
be someone who's willing to go that
extra mile then sure yeah cop out you
know yeah but you know you might be a
little late in the game it might be your
last resort so as it stands though uh
yeah I don't know how in the hell they
could defeat bill I think they've raised
the stakes really well because you
eliminate the journals you eliminate
oh great come on don't be trying to
Gravity Falls I have the final stretch I
should be sharp you got this you're so
good not an uncle Stan Stanford no
John help me
we did lose Stanford Sanford is Stanford
yeah why'd you mean like an idiot I'm
trying to do my best for the lane
deception last episode of Gravity Falls
and you're making me feel like a dumbass
oh it is Stanford all right so Stanford
now Han soloed uh sort of he's more
turned into a trophy than he is a which
was what Han Solo was for Boba No not
Boba Jabba the FED Jabba the boat and uh
yeah and I wanna I wanna get to know
these other characters I do wonder what
the X the the title of this episode
stands for I feel like it's going to be
an out um uh acronym or uh what's the
other one an anagram an anagram maybe or
maybe it is some kind of Cipher like
maybe they I'm trying to figure out if
there's any sequence to like do the X's
each stand for you know
some other letter I I like
I can't it's not weirdmageddon because
there's no W yeah there's only one one
eye
well yeah even if the letters stood in
for other letters you know if x would
have to be W but there aren't two W's so
yeah so I'm like I bet somebody out
there online had I if we googled it I
bet there would be an answer to this but
uh because I've seen in the credits
they've done like these kind of uh
letter salad ciphers before yeah I love
the the intro to it I love the I love
everything they're doing with its like
sweeping animation and feels heavily
produced and it's really high quality at
times I I do question if they even
wanted jokes in here sometimes it seems
like sometimes the thing that feels
perfunctory is some of the jokes and
sometimes I get the impression like did
you guys just really want to like double
down on the thread here and maybe not
make so many jokes yeah sometimes I get
the impression you didn't want to make
some jokes you just want to go full on
yeah like mind-bending Sinister about it
and I wonder I mean I wonder if that is
something the show itself has like you
know had to be up against during its run
because like now in this moment in time
as we're watching this the animation uh
landscape is much more embracing of
things that don't have to necessarily
just be funny that can be a bit more
intense or adult or wild or whatever and
so this being sort of in that middle
ground of like it's kind of aimed at
tweens you know I wonder if that was
something that they were always kind of
doing uh a back and forth about you know
I wonder this too John wonders is a
wonderful thing and also getting a
chance to see Zeus rise to the occasion
you know he's down and dirty and now he
gets to be handyman in the apocalypse
and Wendy like the payoff of all that
things about you know her family being
um oh God I need to be sharp It's the
final episode Dexter tribal Woodsman
Lumberjacks yeah yeah that's the word
um being uh Lumber men in the woods
uh gotta use big words here Ian Woody's
the key to sounding and smart and
seeming like I do stuff in my life uh
big words coming in big words uh come on
uh evocative sure
arousing sure when she's uh like that
that's like percolating and she's got
did she age during the summer can I make
that joke sure she aged enough to be of
a [ __ ] in one supper however old she
started
no I mean I I've always liked the
characters I like the tough down and
dirty girls so no I mean what I'm saying
is what's really cool is a chance to get
to see her um use a lot of those skills
from her family because she's always
like her family has always been
portrayed as The Lumberjack people and
she's always been the modern girl in the
family and for her to get to really show
this side of her which we've only got in
teases of before it's great to see her
like fully embrace it I'm like oh yeah
no this Line's up with her character
extremely well and now we're seeing a
good payoff for it and keep hoping to
presumably oh my God and also the whole
thing with
um when they're doing the Thor the Dark
World hopping through Realms thing yeah
and stuff and it kept changing the
animation and they've got the real life
people yeah that was I think that's
gotta be I I keep reading his name
something Ritter uh yeah but it was
definitely John Ritter it was John
Ritter Kyle Ritter Kyle Ritter house yes
writtenhouse I think it's Kyle Ritter
Kyle Ritter and then Linda Cardellini
yes Jason Ritter Jason Ritter there you
go I've seen this guy's face before
wow what a great treat that is so cool
they gotta do that
oh that's who voices Mabel yeah Kristen
schallapps oh my God how did I not put
that together she's so funny she's got
she is in like a great position in terms
of like Hollywood because she has like
the absolute perfect voice for animation
but also she does so much live action
stuff too how did I really never put
that together
oh it is Alex Hurst is Bill Cipher too
huh
damn it and he does Grunkle see this
he's good at doing old Guy voices no I'm
like what is this guy's real voice
sounds like but who voices Stanford
I can't pinpoint that voice no it's
impossible I don't know
kind of sounds like uh JK Rowling that's
it creator of the the Percy Jackson
series of course well
um yeah guys we're off to a great start
with the weirdmageddon or is this
episode's called ex expelliosis Isaac's
Road uh thank you guys for being here
um this is gonna be an amazing journey
that we are going on I feel like it's
going to be like taking Ayahuasca yeah
a real cleansing of the Mind and Spirit
and all the darkness all scrambled into
one omelet
so yeah guys we'll uh catch you soon I
think I sounded incredibly sharp and
focused and
and uh
um and I just sounded like a dunce
uh
yeah
Keen uh conscientious sharp I already
said sharp uh insightful
discerning
observant
yeah end of video